so let's say I'm a muslim-american okay
and I don't like the way the government
has trampled on the civil liberties of
members of my community should I then
take a rifle and go occupy the
Department of Homeland Security all
we're doing is is protecting that
livelihood of the people here so we're
walking on to Ground Zero of the
occupation of armed men here at the
Malheur National Wildlife Refuge they've
taken over these federal buildings I'm
told they're actually in there the
control room of this militia standoff
well I thought a militia standoff that's
standoff well it's not even really a
standoff a lot of people around the
country are watching this and they're
looking at you guys like these white
guys that came in with their weapons
kind of racist white guys well there's
no point I froze all black guys when we
say those black guys now they're
profiling a lot of people around the
country are looking at what's happening
here and looking at the fact that
there's really no law enforcement around
here and the feds haven't come in and
they say that if this was a group of
African Americans protesting and if it
was a group of Muslim Americans for
example the response has been and would
be a lot more different and it would be
a lot more forceful well my heart goes
out to anyone who has violence
perpetrated upon them okay and and we we
welcome any support from from any deal
from from any community and freedom has
no no color its colorblind
it belongs to all race color and Creed
for myself
you know I worked hard with my own money
to buy my ranch okay a lifetime dream to
have my own and it take a lot to get
there and so that's all we're doing is
is our own personal property our own
personal livelihood our own personal
lives
I understand but what's it would say
that's it so if there's a Muslim in the
same situation or
a Native American and the same thing
more certainly they should should kindly
and and as gently as possible protect
their own life liberty and property near
the entrance I spotted a familiar face
jon ritzheimer the ex-marine who
organized an armed protest in front of a
Phoenix mosque last year and who created
a website selling anti Islamic gear and
so I had to ask a lot of people are
saying imagine if Muslim Americans took
up arms and protested the federal
government what would the response have
been there is a double standard there no
comment do you think they would have
gotten away with it as you guys are
can I see and I ask you that cuz I see a
gun right here right there this is not
about religion
this is not about this is this year is
not about a religion what is it about
so you're saying Muslim Americans well
what do we have here
all I see down in there is Americans
yeah your this is you go people are
saying they're white Americans and with
that they have white privilege that they
can get away with certain things that
people of color might not we've had we
have people of color color they've shown
up here yeah yeah John we're talking
about who owns the land and yesterday a
Native American Paiute Tribe who claimed
this as their ancestral land they're
saying you guys need to leave and that
this is their ancestral land that they
were run off from and killed what you
have to say about that do you
acknowledge that I'm open to a dialogue
about it and learn about it but it
I I'm not educated enough on that too I
don't I haven't heard them they I
haven't seen them so history invite them
into the conversation bring it in the
plot thickens
[Music]